yes this isn't going to be exactly the
continuation of yesterday's talk i'm
going to just go over the parts of
yesterday's talk that you may have seen
really fast and then hopefully move on
um
all right
okay so the title of the talk is
collaborative filtering with low regret
if you want to give recommendations say
imagine amazon or something
so the setup is pretty simple there's a
bunch of users
items
you can think of them as a range in a
matrix
all right and there's some true value
let's think binary so plus one minus one
you like or dislike an item for each
user in each item
but obviously you don't see this
and what you would like is to
like one by one give the users items
that they like right but the point the
reason why this is not obvious is
because you don't actually see this so
just a bit of notation
there's
l
u i is the entry of this matrix
okay so once we have this notation lui
we're going to think of a user actually
as sort of equivalent to
the row vector of the items
so l u dot it's a vector
we also think of an item is
corresponding to a column vector
so i might say something like items are
similar to each other all that means is
if you look at the columns
the columns are similar and similar say
according to some
cosine distance or their inner product
is relatively big
okay so now the way this works is
work sequentially
one by one
so at time one two and so on
you recommend a new item to a user and
they give you feedback they like it or
dislike it and then you continue okay so
there's just sequential one by one
filling in entries of this matrix
so that's right
emphasize this new um dev red emphasized
yesterday
um
and it's important for various reasons
and we'll go a little bit into that in a
moment
okay so we're gonna recommend item i sub
t to user u sub t
user u sub t is going to be uniformly at
random
selected
from
the whole pool of users
to which there's 10. i'm going to add an
n here
n is important don't forget what n is
the number of users in the system um
okay so you recommend an item to a user
it's a new item
so you don't recommend the same movie
over and over again then you get
feedback
bandit feedback right so you just get
feedback on the thing that you
you chose
okay great so this is the setup um how
do we measure our performance
so expected regret is what we're going
to use
at
some arbitrary finite time t to expected
regret is
normalizing my number of users
expected value of
sum over all the times
1 minus this l of u t i t
all right so we're comparing ourselves
to what you would do if you just gave a
good recommendation that'd be plus one
and um
so this regret is is uh
is two if you give a bad recommendation
zero if you give a good one so obviously
you want a low regret that's good
performance
uh that's a good question it's sort of
arbitrary how you normalize it but
yeah sorry that there's a maybe that's
oh okay
yeah good now it's better right okay so
good point
okay
good so yeah each time you recommend a
new item and so yeah okay um
good so two things to emphasize and i
won't go into details is that this looks
like a matrix completion problem it sort
of is but it's different than the
standard formulation where you observe
an entry um or some random subset of
entries and just want to complete the
whole matrix it's online you're
in here you can adapt to what you've
recommended so far and so on so it's a
different setting
also this regret is different than the
standard
performance metric for matrix completion
okay
and then one other point is that so this
looks like a multi or magnet problem in
some ways it's actually different and
one of the key differences is that you
recommend a new item
and
that contrasts strongly with the multi
or mandate notion of optimality which
basically to recommend the best item
over and over and over again so that's
not so good
if we're doing recommendations so okay
new entry new entry
yeah all right so
okay final bit of uh
notations the probability that a random
user
likes
a random item
so i'm pretty defined near some constant
you can think of it as like a third or
something um okay so
theorem
sorry yeah
the setup is like the world randomly
picks a user what do you think of the
user randomly decides to log on to
amazon and wants a recommendation yeah
and then and then you're tasked with
picking
an item that they haven't been been
shown before yeah so okay good so this
is a sort of extreme situation where
whatever you recommend to them they
they consume it and
then after they're consumed they don't
want the same item again
okay so the theorem is this plot and
double brush sort of showed it i'll just
go over it very quickly
okay so we're going to plot the regret
at time t as a function of time
all right so initially
if your
recommendations are useless they're
completely at random
then the slope here is going to be 2
minus two new
okay and this is
just random guessing and this happens
until
some time that we call t cold start
after this time things get better
one gets a sort of
concave down looking thing
and it's linear
and the regret scales like big o of t to
the
v plus
two and then finally there's this
d max
at which point
the slope doesn't decrease and there's
some fixed slope
which is a function of the number of
users and gets smaller as number of
users
increases okay so t cold start is a
constant
power roughly some constant times d and
i'm not actually going to say what d is
i'll just say roughly what it is and
then t max is these with some constant
times number of users
plus one over
four d plus two okay
okay so d
and everett spent a little while kind of
discussing this and i'm not going to
discuss it at all but it's the measure
it's a certain measure
to a measure
of complexity
oh quite a space
okay um
good so what are the goals
and the remaining what's the
distribution that you're drawing the
users or items from
so at the moment there is no
distribution um
you can just think of there is some
matrix
likes random item
oh this is the sorry this is new
if you were to select the random entry
of this matrix it's essentially the
density of
plus ones so it's like you're given a
matrix
i mean you aren't given it but it exists
there's there's some the assumption is
that there's some true preferences if
people you don't know what it is and
then
you go one by one okay
all right so what are the goals i guess
i have
roughly nine to ten minutes so
there's two goals um we want to
understand very briefly
devorah mentioned item item
collaborative filtering
as compared to user user
and we'll
get some intuition
these two really quick and then
why can we hope for
sublinear regret and what does that mean
and why is that good
okay
good
why is the linear regret and how do we
achieve it um we'll see maybe only get
into the first one but hopefully the
second one so
okay so we're gonna start with
so obviously the high level goal is to
get the best possible regret um
so if i were to get a regret that looks
like this
and that's better and slower
sorry
if instead of this setting you're just
in a setting where you're allowed to
pick any
um user item pair that's not yet been
been queried
so meaning you can choose which user
you're giving a recommendation to
is it actually strictly better or that's
a good question i'm not totally sure um
i mean there's a lot of settings where
that's actually the setting
okay
all right so there's an example we're
just going to look at um
an example matrix and see what what we
can do so
this example matrix is going to have a
block form
i'm going to shade in if the whole block
is plus one
otherwise it's all minus one
okay
um good so
let's just really
briefly see what does user user
collaborative filtering do
and everett mentioned this well you find
a user that's similar so by the way i'll
just emphasize there's n users here but
there's only four sort of types of users
and that is one thing
that is one then it's not so good
but where does that trip right here yeah
that's what i don't understand
um
yeah
okay because you have an interface
so epsilon n is going to be
effectively this if if n is
one
right you could have this one so this is
hidden in the constant c
so n is to be just louder than some
fixed constant 50.
i mean the performance gets better and
better then it gets bigger um it doesn't
have i mean and could be one number what
is this break depends on why i don't
think it breaks but i think the slope
here is just the same so and sort of t
max ends up being
there's also linear forces there's no
sub-linear reporting if you have an iid
matrix again there's no sublinear
portion right just a one oh yeah
okay so user user collaborative
filtering step one is uh find a user
similar to you
what that means is if you're a
particular user here
so this is maybe i think
user will be
using u
this is some other user w
and these two users have identical
preferences right the rows are the same
so we say these are similar and maybe
some other users are different so you
find a user that's similar and then you
recommend
an item that
they like so
okay so
user you know user w has
like this item you can recommend that to
user u um
okay and the basic uh
idea behind finding a user that's
similar as you're comparing these two
rows
okay so you're going to
reveal some of the entries in the two
rows and you decide they're similar if
you know most of the revealed entries
are in agreement and you can convince
yourself that under most situations it
takes log
log k
entries revealed where entries uh where
k is the number of blocks so
k types are going to be k blocks
sorry k you know groupings
k types of users okay groupings here
there's going to be also k
types of items and just an example so
here it's four
all right so this is just the first
thing is i want to compare two users are
they similar i need a bunch of items to
to measure for this
this is sort of an exercise you can
check um okay good so i'll have enough
time at least to compare
user using item item um
okay so item item collaborative
filtering um find
an item
similar
to
item
that i like
and you can recommend it
the basic thing that
one does here is the similarity between
items
and this is sort of the punch line of
the the whole thing
the whole paper and the whole result is
that
it's actually pretty easy to compare two
items so
this is
item i item j
okay item i and j are similar if most
users agree on them
now you can ask yourself how in the
world am i going to figure out if two
items are similar i just can sample a
bunch of different users
have them rate both items and i can get
an estimate of the inner product of
these two columns right so this is
seems sort of trivial i'm just one i'm
comparing rows and one i'm comparing
columns but there's actually something
interesting going on which is that
the users can do this in parallel right
you can have all the users or a bunch of
users write two items and get really
accurate measures of similarity if you
want to check if two users are similar
then from the user's perspective they
have to write a bunch of items so it's
costly and it's painful okay so
um
let's see
i guess i have three or four minutes um
because this is one inside and this
without going into details this shows
that
you can start giving good
recommendations really fast okay deborah
mentioned a little bit the cold start
the idea is you can just quickly tell
which items are similar to the ones
you've seen and give those and so that
gives rise to an algorithm which is
based on a basic subroutine
basic subroutine is
check whether two items are similar
and
you just query a bunch of users on both
items you can check if they're similar
the algorithm that results from that
give a little bit of a picture so you
start by so you can think of each item
according to here as a n dimensional
plus one minus one vector so we have all
the points here
now by these queries we can we can put
an edge if two items are similar
we can partition the space into items
that are similar to one another and draw
sort of a
bubble here
okay so the algorithm has this sort of
exploration phase where it
determines subsets of items that are
similar to one another you can think of
it as constructing an epsilon net okay
and then
if you want to start giving
recommendations what users do is they
check a item so maybe a user
writes this item and if it likes this
item
then probably the user will like all the
rest of the items that are similar to
that item so
then you can recommend all of those so
again if user doesn't like this item
then you can just toss out all of these
there's sort of two phases one you use
the parallelism to quickly determine
which items are similar to which other
ones
and then you can
have individual users sort of find which
groups they like
okay so
going back to regret picture
in order to get this initial sort of
clustering of the items the similarities
it takes some small amount of time that
it's shared among all the users
and then things get better and better
and the reason why they get better is
because you can refine the accuracy of
your partition okay so
this is the similarity measure is going
to get more and more refined and you
start getting better and better
recommendations because these items are
more similar um
it's a high-level algorithm i guess i'll
stop there
take any questions so the question i
mean what if there's two types of users
that are very different
perfect yeah so how does this discover
that
right one type of user has the exact
opposite preference of the other type of
user
and so you compare two items and you say
these items are similar but
half users like it and have to have
don't right okay so this is this kind of
situation
i've used user type one user type too
if items are similar then the user will
agree on that i don't
so i can think of it from other
perspective but if i'm trying to
recommend the item to this user
i can look at this call and i can find
another item that's similar it comes
here and the user will so you can think
of the items being similar as most users
agreeing on that
right
like you can probably build counter
examples they get bigger right
so in this case right if two items are
similar in this it's also the groups are
similar
so like the item is telling you the
group as well the user so so that's a
general thing that's true is if you
specify the structure over the items
that determines the matrix and that
determines therefore the structure of
the users
right
good so the converse is still in
progress it hasn't been finished yet but
there there will be a converse soon
another question
it seems to me i mean for a fixed matrix
right
what can help you gain i mean the only
side information
how about the following algorithm so
each time
you have to recommend something you just
look
through the you know for the columns
and see which one has density of
revealed enter is you know
below mu so then you know roughly you
expect a good
lots of plus ones in that column so then
you kind of bias your recommendation
towards there because no so there's
something going on that i didn't that i
glossed over that's aside from just how
good the item is in general um there's
something that allows you to find items
that are similar to one another
and that's that's what allows you to
give good recommendations a certain
structure in the space of items and
that's there's all the stuff with this
dimensionality of the item space and
things that i didn't go into
right but if if i know that these items
are actually identical then i'm in good
shape because like once a user finds
that they like one of them they're for
sure going to like the other
other items because all users agree on
those items
this is what d is
d is somehow related to
how hard it is to uh
use the of the matrix
distribution
so forget the distribution yeah so
there's d there's n
there's no distribution yeah
later because we have one more talk this
morning than we have had all the other
mornings